hello and welcome to this
nexon air talk about how to choose the
right database for your workloads
i'm robert coopers i'm a google cloud
developer advocate and i've worked with
storage and databases for the majority
of my time here at google
you can find me on twitter with at host0
now if we look at application and
database migration journeys we
do understand that these are dynamic and
diverse
so if you are coming from an on-premises
system and moving into the cloud
if you're moving from one cloud to
another or if you're looking at a
multi-cloud strategy even if you
are in the business of developing
something new from scratch
or extending your applications with new
applications from scratch
we want to meet you where you are and
want to support you in those journeys
so today i want to focus on three major
journeys here
first one is migration so like for like
migration
lift and shift lift and optimize here
you're coming from a
system that you're familiar with and you
won't like to stay
with but you want to move into the cloud
reducing
your tco for instance or having
actually the possibility for faster
migrations
fewer applications rewrites and enable
the modernization once you are
on the cloud second i want to talk about
monetization journeys here you are
looking at like
challenges that you have with your
existing databases
where you want to move off your existing
databases
and want to move on a cloud native
database for instance or
one of our managed open source solutions
this can help you reduce and eliminate
reliance on a single database it allows
you to rethink how you're using your
databases for instance consolidating
many databases into one
or changing the database that you're
using
and third i want to touch on innovation
and transformation
here i want to focus on like what are
the databases that we are offering
as fully managed solutions to remove the
tile
from your plate so that you can
concentrate on solving and
building the things that your customers
need here you have the ability to really
tap into systems that are scalable
available
sla backed and that help you to advance
your business
so let's start with migrate so the
migration journey to be successful
is a multi-step process and i want to
touch on this because this is important
if you want to have a successful
database migration you start with
assessment and discovery you want to see
like where you are
where you're coming from and what are
the criterias along the way
that build success make these criterias
in a way that you can
check on your journey your success
criterias along the way
then you want to set up this environment
so there are different ways of doing
this you can basically start an
organization google cloud
create your projects set up network
peering set up private networks
to always have your data secure when
you're moving it or
if you have a lot of data you can use
something like transfer appliance
that we are offering which we are
shipping to your data center where you
can load data onto it ship it back
and then it gets loaded into gcs where
you can load it back into a database of
your choice
then you have the data migration of
course check with monitoring if this
migration is going well
validate it and then have always a
strategy
of if something goes wrong how to roll
back especially if you do
online migration you want to have
rollback strategies and you want to have
them tested
so what are the options you see here on
the left that we have
there are a lot of databases that are
around there are open source databases
there are third-party databases there
are relational databases
key value store column store caches
really like streaming databases a lot of
databases that are
on now if you look at those database
where can you end up
on google cloud so you see on the right
we have
infrastructure as a service or managed
databases that you can
choose to end up especially for
homogeneous migration
you want to look if your database is iso
supported by
our fully managed services or you can
also
help get help from our managed partners
to
go into those solutions so let's assume
for instance if you have all those
databases on the left side
you can always go the way and
self-manage them on compute engine
or kubernetes engine if you like now if
you
are using for instance mysql postgresql
sql server you can use one of our
managed solutions with cloud sql
now for hbase for instance if you have
hbase workloads
our cloud bigtable managed solution and
cloud native database support has an
hbase api and so you can end up with
your workloads
for hbase workloads in cloud bigtable
directly
now if you looking into cache solutions
you can use cloud memory store
or for redis for instance we also have a
managed partner solutions with our open
source
partners to provide you a fully managed
solution that is integrated
with billing that is integrated with
monitoring and easily accessible through
the marketplace
and then last but not least we also have
bare metal solutions so bare metal
solution i will go a little bit more in
detail
later but that also allows you to bring
your third-party database workloads
closer to our data centers
so i want to focus a bit on sql how do
we support you
in sql migration so one of the things
that for instance with mysql
supporters is external replication so
you can
like set up external replication of your
existing mysql databases
on premises or in another cloud and this
way catch up
with your data in our cloud on cloud sql
and then switch over
we have also a lot of other
functionality that helps you to
move your data and your applications
into cloud
now i want to point out here that we are
partnering with a lot of
like migration partners you see a
screenshot of logos
down there in the slide and if you
basically
want to have help if you want to have
experienced partners
experienced partners in your migration
journey please feel free to reach out to
those migration partners that have done
model migration successfully onto cloud
sql
and last but not least i also wanted to
point out that you
can get more information on what
features we have for instance with cloud
sql coming and how to
migrate or recover with cloud sql
in the talks that you see in the learn
more section now what is bare metal
solution
with bare metal solution we allow you to
migrate
or move your oracle workloads closer to
google cloud
so maybe you can't move off oracle right
now
or you don't want to move at a later
point and you want to move your central
workflow it's closer to google cloud
now with peripheral solution you have
some
solution that is possible in the sense
of that we have purpose-built hardware
that is certified that brings your
workloads
closer to google cloud we have
integrated billing
this is a very low latency setup
for our with our data centers and we
allow you to bring your own dbas
or your service integration partners
that you prefer
with this solution now if you want to
learn more about bare metal solutions
please check out the
talk dbs 2 213.
all right with this i want to go into
the modern administration section of
this talk
so again i want to touch on also a
modernization
journey is something that where you need
to look at the multiple steps that
you're plotting on during this journey
now this is a little bit more complex
you see here i
didn't do justice with just adding this
app in the migration step but like each
of this step is touched if you do a
modernization journey
now in a modernization journey you have
things like you have to think about okay
i might have to do a data model
transformation
i have to do my data transformation with
my move into the cloud
there are maybe different things that
you need to
change in your apps to make that
actually possible but again
all this should be starting at an
assessment do pocs
set up the success criteria set up the
environment
and have strategies if something goes
wrong
now there are three main cloud data
native databases that i want to touch on
here for
your migration journeys number one is
firestore so firestore is our fast
fully managed serverless nosql cloud
database
so it allows you to especially build
really powerful
web and mobile applications it is a
document based database and it allows
you also to
sync your devices in real time now
bigtable is a fast and fully managed
white column database or key value nosql
database
that allows you low latency scalability
and reliability
for massive workloads where you need
like fast lookups
fast rights and and fast scans
now cloud spliner is our database that
addresses the
old tp and relational database market
with cloud spanner
you have an enterprise great globally
distributed and strongly consistent
sql database that has asset
functionalities and that you have
basically built
in this other disaster recovery and high
availability
with horizontal scale now what do we see
in our customers what are the journeys
that we see
a lot of times so here i want to point
out that for instance for the otp and
sql
database modernization on workloads we
see a lot of
customers that hit certain challenges
with
their existing relational databases and
they want to move into a more managed
scalable and sla backed solution
so many of those customers are looking
at cloud spanner at the destination
from a relational database now here
challenges are addressed with
scalability you have an
sla up to five nines you have built in
high availability and disaster recovery
so there are many things that help you
basically making this decision
now other workloads that you can see is
for instance cassandra workloads
now there there's a little bit of a
differentiation here that you have to
look at
so for cassandra workload it's really
important is why did you
move to cassandra in the first place did
you try to
address a challenge like you
had scalability issues and you were
saying okay
i wanted to address the scalability
issue
challenge and that's why i moved to
cassandra which
is a horizontal scalable database system
by by that you sacrifice some of the
consistencies
qualities that you have with a
relational database
now if you weren't like happy with
sacrificing these constraints
like the relational constraints that you
have the consistency constraints that
you
have in your workloads and you had to
build this into your application which
is
aerothrone and difficult and quite an
overhead
then many of those customers are
actually moving to cloud spanner because
you get back you the consistency but you
keep the horizontal scalability before
your workloads
now if you move to cassandra because of
the scalability
the horizontal scalability and you find
sacrificing the
the consistent sequence in here then
we see customers moving to cloud
bigtable where you have row level
consistency
but eventually consistency for
replication
across zones and regions now if you for
instance come
from a document store we see quite
quite a lot of customers that are
looking for instance moving to firestore
as a destination from mongodb for
instance
all right so what how do we support you
actually in this database modernization
so there are
quite a couple of things that you can
look at in for this
for this support in the modernization on
the one hand we are building more and
more tools that help you
migrate so we are integrating with
industry standards like gdbc and
hibernate
we are integrating with very popular
frameworks like spring cloud integration
for instance
and we provide you with tools for fast
iterative development that you can do
for instance the local emulators help
you to fast
iterate and develop locally without
having to set up
a database like cloud span or bigtable
database
in the cloud and you have all this
overhead there
also by moving into one of our
onto one of our cloud databases cloud
native databases you get all the other
features as well
so you get like high availability all
the scalability
and the integrations that come for like
monitoring
or optimizing your databases
now you might ask okay is that the only
thing that i need like if i make a
decision
to which database to move and it is not
you have to differentiate between two
main areas that i see here one is what
are the technical considerations that we
have touched on already
in this talk and what are the business
considerations right
so taking into consideration again just
in a
briefly what are the tools and
integration and support you get on the
technical side right what are the
communities things like that
what is the data model that you have to
go into
and what are the consistency
requirements that you have for your
workloads
now on the other end the business
consideration is things like
can you reuse the skills that you have
already in your teams
in your companies is there a certain sla
that you need
do you need a certain managed
functionality what is the security
requirements compliance certification
things like that
so there are many criteria that you need
and want to
look at when you make your choice for a
database
now that said for all the cloud data
data iterative databases that we offer
they are all sla backed they all come
with data encryption in flight and
at rest and they all are built
for scalability and availability
so with this i want to focus on like
okay what are the databases over that
you can end up with
especially for your innovation and
transformation journeys
first cloud spanner so why would you
choose cloud spanner
first it is a fully managed asset in a
relational database
it comes with a built-in high
availability so data
is distributed and replicated across
zones and for our multi-regional setups
across
regions so if one zone goes down
you your database will still be
available now
the second thing is you are provisioning
the database for what you need
here you can scale flexibly horizontally
right so you are you have an online
elastic capacity scaling
and that is actually in a matter of
minutes that you can scale
so you're just gonna go either use an
api or our console
to scale your database depending or
instance actually depending on the load
that you have
and a new feature that you just added
recently you can do
things like query optimization version
pinning where
if you have a query optimizer that we
have released that you like and
you want to test a new version before
you actually go
in with this for your production
workloads you have the ability to
actually
choose which kind of optimizations you
want to have for your workloads
now we see a lot of uptake for cloud
spanner in
many many many verticals and workload
different diverse workloads
especially things where you need the
consistency constraints where you need
the asset
capabilities of this database
now for cloud bigtable here we're
looking at a
really really performant key value of
white column
database we see a lot of things like log
or anything where you need like fast
lookups but cloud bigtable is optimized
for fast ingress and fast searches so
random reads you slough bigtable also
has linear scalability so depending on
your workloads
depending on your traffic that you have
you can flexibly scale
linearly for your workloads which is
very very powerful
again cloud bigtable is a fully managed
database it comes with
many many client libraries in automatic
languages
and you have tools integration like the
key visualizer that helps you optimize
your
schemas i also want to mention here if
you are
going onto one of our cloud native
databases
these get better over time so cloud
bigtable for instance is a database that
we have developed and started develop
15 years ago it hasn't made through many
many iterations and optimizations
along the way now if you are betting on
one of the cloud native databases we are
constantly optimizing
the hardware the network the
functionality under the hood and you
just get that out of the box
you don't have to self-manage for
instance the operating system you don't
have to
run pen patches or things like that and
updates for your self-managed workloads
here everything is fully managed for you
now firestore is the database that is
currently has the highest net promoter
score
firestore is very easy to start with and
again it's a serverless
fully managed database where you pay for
what you get
and you pay for what you use that is
important here and
it comes with many many integrations for
ios
android web clients you find server
client libraries
but a feature that i really really like
for firestore is the real time
synchronization between devices and
that can be a mobile device with android
ios or it can be a web application
it is very easy to set up you don't have
to
do write a lot of code it basically
comes out of the box
another feature which comes out of box
here is that you have offline support
so even if you have connection
challenges
we do all the things behind the scenes
to make sure that your data
is cached and the app experience is
almost uninterrupted
if your people or your users and your
customers go
go offline we see with firestore that
many many companies are actually using
firestore to extend and modernize their
application in front of legacy
setups so for instance if you want to
add like a more natural
and more modern mobile application
experience firestore is like one of the
number one
choices here to achieve that with your
existing
backends now i don't want to say that
you only want to end up in our cloud
native situation
databases there are many situations
where you might want to end up
in an open source database now with
our managed open source solutions you
can do just that
and remember here is it's about taking
away the toil from you
with our managed solutions we are and
our partners
are taking care of things like operating
system patches
database patches keeping everything
secure
in the background and updating the back
end in the sense of that
you get like you can choose when you
want to have your new functionalities
coming in
with your managed solutions but it's a
much less toil it is
integrated with our monitoring and our
logging tools
and integrated with the billing
facilities as well
now you might have wondered there wasn't
any
data analytics database so far so i want
to actually bring in bigquery here which
is our serverless fully managed petabyte
scale data warehouse system
so with bigquery you can run analytics
across
petabytes of data in minutes or
terabytes of data in seconds
and it's very feature rich it has a lot
of features like
ml integration you have a natural
language query interface now that is
just released you have an sql interface
so it speaks sql so can you
again reuse your skills that you are
already familiar with
what's really powerful with bigquery is
in the integration with
other systems so bigquery allows you to
for instance run
federated queries into cloud sql
databases
by doing this you don't need to move
your data from cloud sql for instance to
bigquery
you can just query your data directly
from bigquery and we also just recently
announced that
it's possible to actually query data in
other clouds with bigquery as well
so with this just let's get all this
onto one slide
so here you see the full data management
portfolio
that we are offering ourselves as well
as
our with our partners and you we don't
stop there right you can always
run your database of choice that if even
if it's not supported by
us directly or by our partners you can
always run it on our
infrastructure so for instance if you
look at like
hana or ibm db2 or things like that you
can always run then
directly on gce and in kubernetes
so there are many ways like from
in-memory
non-relational relational data
warehouses everything here
you see that can be accomplished with
our database and data management
portfolio
now i want to have a little different
view here
as my last slide before i close out this
talk
so here you see the different data model
schemas
that are available and are supported by
our database
systems and solutions now you see that
many of those are either
supported by our fully managed offerings
by our client
cloud native offerings or through our
partner
offerings that we have here and just for
you for reference and help
if you are in the business of moving
from one cloud to another
or you want to set up a multi-cloud
environment we have also put the systems
in other cloud
cloud providers so you have something
that you can match up for our
database solutions all right
so with this please tune in into the
sections and breakout talks that are
available
on next on air there are many really
really great talks that are
coming out and that are really
interesting to watch many go in a little
bit more detail or a lot more detail
and how to migrate your workloads onto
google cloud
i also want to especially recommend you
to watch the solution keynote what's new
with database management and also check
out
our showcase demos that are available
at cloud with google.com next sf demos
under data management databases
all right with this thank you very much
for tuning in i hope this was helpful
and please feel free to reach out to me
for instance on twitter
at hostiosd thank you